HAVE TUNED INTO THIS SCHIFF SHAM
SHOW AND FOR GOOD REASONS.
HERE, WITH REACTION TO ALL THIS,
CONGRESSWOMAN, ELISE STEFANIK,
BY THE WAY, SHE COMES OUT OF
THESE HEARINGS IN MY MIND A NEW
STAR OF THE REPUBLICAN HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: CONGRESSWOMAN, LET US
BEGIN WITH YOU.
I WATCHED YOU.
I'VE GOT TO SAY, PHENOMENAL JOB
AND THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU'VE
DONE.
>> Elise: THANK YOU.
I JUST FOCUS ON THE FOX AND IT
IS CLEAR AS EVERY DAY THAT GOES
BY THAT DEMOCRATS CASE FOR
IMPEACHMENT IS CRUMBLING.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS BEEN A FAILURE
AND AGAIN, THE FACTS REMAIN THE
SAME.
UKRAINE.
THERE WAS NO QUID PRO QUO, AND
THERE WAS NO INVESTIGATION INTO
THE BIDENS.
IN FACT, THE ONLY INVESTIGATION
WAS INTO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, BUT YET,
ADAM SCHIFF CONTINUES HIS REGIME
OF SECRECY.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN SUCH AN
OUTSPOKEN ADVOCATE OF THE FACTS,
I HAVE BEEN ATTACKED BY THE
HOLLYWOOD LEFT.
I NEED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
STEP UP, DONATE AT FIGHT
SCHIFF.COM TO HELP ME SPEAK FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT.
>> Sean: GOOD FOR YOU FOR
STEPPING OUT.
ANY TIME YOU STEP OUT, YOU TAKE
A RISK.
I SAID THIS TO KEVIN McCARTHY
LAST NIGHT.
I WILL SAY THIS TO YOU.
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER, AND
I'VE BEEN VERY CRITICAL OF
REPUBLICANS.
YOU'VE HEARD ME.
WHEN YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE A
BACKBONE AND YOU ARE WEAK, AND
YOU ARE VISION LISTS, AND I
THINK I'M PRETTY LOUD ON MY --
THIS WAS REPUBLICANS AT THEIR
BEST THIS WEEK.
THEY WERE PREPARED.
THEY FOUGHT IT OUT AND THEY WON.
>> YEAH SEAN.
I CAN'T BE MORE PROUD OF OUR
MEMBERS OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE WHO ASK THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS, WHO FOCUSED ON THE
FACTS.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS HAS BEEN
ABOUT FROM THE BEGINNING FOR US,
FOR ADAM SCHIFF, IT WAS ABOUT
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH FACTS.
HE VETOED OUR WITNESSES.
HE SHOT US OUT OF THOSE
HEARINGS.
WHEN I BROUGHT A FEW OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO THE SCHIFF, WHERE
WE WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON HE LITERALLY
RAN OUT OF THE PACK ROOM WITH
THE WITNESS.
WHAT HAS HE BEEN TRYING TO HIDE?
HE'S GOT NO CASE.
THERE LITERALLY IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT THERE WAS ANY COLLUSION.
I THOUGHT FOR SO MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS, LOOK, ASKING TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
THAT MAKES FOR A TARGET ON THE
LEFT.
THAT SITE SHE'S TALKING ABOUT, I
THINK PEOPLE ARE FED UP WITH THE
BULLYING, THE INTIMIDATION
THAT'S COMING FROM THE LEFT, THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE CLAIMING QUIT
PRO QUOTE, THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE OUT THERE.
IT STARTED WITH JOE BIDEN.
HE WAS THE ORIGINAL QUID PRO
QUO, WHO SAID THAT I AM LEAVING
WITH THE DOLLARS.
THEY FIRED THE GUY.
THEN, JOE BIDEN WANTS TO RUN OFF
INTO THE SUNSET AND IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP FOR THAT.
THERE IS NO IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
EVERY STAR DEMOCRAT WITNESS MADE
CLEAR THAT THEY SAW NOTHING.
EVEN THE HEARSAY.
NOT ONE PERSON.
MIKE TURNER, I
MIKE TURNER, YESTERDAY, HE SAID,
HAS ANYONE ON THE PLANET DRAWN A
CONNECTION BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKING FOR MONEY
IN EXCHANGE FOR INVESTIGATIONS?
NOT ONE PERSON.
UKRAINIAN FOREIGN MINISTER SAID
THAT IT NEVER HAPPENED.
>> Sean: THE ONLY WITNESS.
HE SAID NO, THIS IS JUST MY
OPINION.
YOU ASKED THE PRESIDENT, WELL,
WHAT DOES HE WANT QUESTION WHAT
HE SAYS, NOTHING.
I DON'T WANT A QUID PRO QUO.
I WANT HIM TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
CONGRESSWOMAN, YOU HAD A VERY
WELL, NOW FAMOUS I GUESS
EXCHANGE WITH THE CONGENITAL
LIAR RUNNING THE SCHIFF SHOW.
IT WAS INTERESTING, BECAUSE YOU
WERE ON FOR A FUNDAMENTAL
FAIRNESS.
NOW, REPUBLICANS HAVE ASKED
WITNESSES TO COME FORWARD.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN GRANTED UP
HIGH ON SCHIFF MOUNTAIN.
>> Elise: THAT'S CORRECT.
THAT'S HOW UNFAIR THIS PROCESS
HAS BEEN.
I WAS THE FIRST MEMBER OF
CONGRESS TO ASK THE QUESTION,
"WHEN DID ADAM SCHIFF TALK TO
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER?"
I WAS --
THE ONE WITNESS THAT ADAM SCHIFF
WON'T CALL IS THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
WHO STARTED OFF THIS ENTIRE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
IN ADDITION, ADAM SCHIFF REFUSES
TO CALL HUNTER BIDEN AND EVERY
SINGLE WITNESS THAT WAS ASKED
THE QUESTION, IS THERE A
POTENTIAL APPEARANCE OF A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST SAID YES.
>> Sean: YOU MEAN ZERO
EXPERIENCE?
THE ONE WHO WAS PAID.
HIS DAD CHOKED ON UKRAINE AND
SAID, YOU AREN'T GETTING THE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LESS YOU FIRE
THE GUY INVESTIGATING MY ZERO
EXPERIENCE.
>> Elise: HUNTER BIDEN IS THE
WITNESS THAT ADAM SCHIFF WILL
NOT CALL.
CERTAINLY, WHEN IT COMES TO MY
DISTRICT, MY CONSTITUENTS WANT
TO HEAR FROM HUNTER BIDEN.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS, SEAN, IS
DESPITE THIS INCREDIBLY PARTISAN
PROCESS, REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED
THE SENATE, AND I AM CONFIDENT
THAT THEY WILL CALL THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND CALL HUNTER
BIDEN TO ACTUALLY GET TO THE
FACTS AND REALLY FOCUS ON THE
CORRUPTION.
>> Sean: IN 348 DAYS, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE GET THE FINAL
SAY.
WHAT WOULD YOU BE?
THE HOUSE MAJORITY LEADER.
THEN, I GUESS THAT COULD HAPPEN,